[Music]
on this tuesday night the eve of an
unprecedented
presidential inauguration amped up
security
for a scaled back swearing in i'm truly
honored to be
your next president the eerie atmosphere
in washington d.c
it's very sad and reflections on the
transition of power
after a tumultuous four years canada's
conservative leader pushes out an mp
with a controversial history
what's the strategy and why now and as
one province considers easing
restrictions
we need to take this cautious approach
another expands
its red alert
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
in washington d.c tonight the stage is
set for the inauguration of the 46th
president of the united states
thousands of american flags are taking
the place of people on the national mall
the political violence and the pandemic
means this inauguration
will be unlike any in american history
this evening president-elect joe biden
and vice president-elect kamala harris
took part in a ceremony
at the lincoln memorial reflecting pool
where 400 lights were illuminated along
the edge of the pool
each light representing one thousand
americans who have died
of covet 19. to heal
we must remember it's hard
sometimes to remember
but that's how we heal it's important
to do that as a nation
good evening and thanks for joining us
there will be more troops than american
civilians in the streets of washington
for this inauguration
it is traditionally a centerpiece of the
peaceful transfer of power
but washington right now is like a
fortress and their fear of more
political violence is real
we have complete coverage tonight
beginning with our washington bureau
chief
jackson proskow jackson
well donna an inauguration is supposed
to be a celebration of a new
administration but that's not the case
this time around with dual crises facing
joe biden
the pandemic and national security
concerns
nothing about this inauguration is
typical instead of cheering crowds
thousands of flags will flutter silently
on the national mall
questions still linger about whether
it's safe to swear in president-elect
joe biden on the steps of the capitol
at least a dozen national guard members
who were set to protect the inauguration
have been relieved of duty over concerns
about potential links to far-right
militias
extremism is not tolerated in any branch
of the united states military
i know these are dark times but there's
always light
an emotional biden is pressing ahead
tears streamed down his face as he bid
farewell to friends and supporters in
delaware before departing for washington
excuse the emotion but
when i die delaware written on my heart
at the white house president trump has
spent his final days in seclusion
recording a farewell message to
supporters that still
does not mention biden by name this week
we
inaugurate a new administration
and pray for its success in keeping
america safe
and prosperous trump is the first
president in more than 150 years to shun
the swearing in of his successor
despite receiving the courtesy himself
four years ago
to not do it i think is really leaving a
blank in democracy
and really hurting the exercise of this
extremely
wonderful moment trump still refuses to
acknowledge he lost the election
as he faces the prospect of a
post-presidential impeachment trial
for inciting the mob that stormed the
capitol the mob
was fed lies they were provoked
by the president and other powerful
people
on his last day in office it's clear
trump's influence is waning
as republican leaders plot how to move
on
from the lie that fractured the nation
toward a new president who has promised
unity
trump will receive a formal send-off
tomorrow morning as he departs for his
new life
in florida but in a sign of how isolated
he is in these final 24 hours in office
his vice president mike pence will not
be there to see him off
instead pence will be right here at the
capitol building for the inauguration of
joe biden
donna it will be a remarkable day
jackson prosco in washington thanks
the secret service is in charge of
security at the inauguration and it has
never been more
tense areas around the white house and
the capitol are locked down
americans have been told to stay home
and watch the whole thing on tv
the fbi has been vetting the thousands
of national guard troops brought in from
across the country
the feeling seems to be just get through
the day without any political violence
mike armstrong is in washington tonight
too and gives us a sense
of what it's like
they are just about everywhere national
guard soldiers seem to be on every
corner in downtown washington
so it's like you can't get to work you
can't go nowhere it's like gated
everywhere it's crazy
the security perimeter around the
capitol and the national mall
is bigger than it's ever been before for
an inauguration
and there are more soldiers than ever in
history to enforce it
there are 25 000 national guard this
year more than three times as many
compared to donald trump's inauguration
four years ago only eight thousand this
feels different since the pandemic it's
always been like kind of
empty but now it's actually it's very
sad
for businesses in the area after months
of pain from the pandemic
this is another blow they usually get a
bump in inauguration years
for the first obama inauguration in 2009
hotels were at 97.2 percent occupancy
the trump inauguration in 2017 was
smaller but there was also the women's
march the next day
again hotels were almost full at 95.2
percent
since the january 6th siege at the
capitol hotels have been busy
but fielding cancellations even with the
pandemic there was still a desire to
come and witness and be
in washington dc all those those
opportunities went away just to give you
an idea of what it's like to be here in
downtown dc we're about three blocks
north of the white house you can see
every street is blocked off by national
guard or police
in fact every alley as well and then you
get another security perimeter
barriers fencing more guards this one
you can walk through
but if you do you end up at another
security perimeter this one being
guarded by
dozens of national guard no one is
getting anywhere near capitol hill the
national mall
or the white house right now one
question now
is how long this extra security lasts
dc's mayor says she hopes things loosen
up after the inauguration but that she
understands that may take a while
the soldiers who've been sent in from
every state in the country
are still waiting to find out when
they'll head home don't know we came a
week early
we're here for this week and then we
have no plans to go home yet
now it will take a while for life here
to return to even a semblance of
normality
most businesses downtown have shut down
boarded up
and basically said call me when it's
over
mike armstrong global news washington
global news will have live coverage of
the inauguration from washington d.c
tomorrow morning at 11 eastern 8
pacific when joe biden takes the oath of
office tomorrow he does take on a
country in the midst of deep trauma
more than 24 million americans have now
been infected with the coronavirus
more than four hundred thousand have
died one of the hardest hit regions is
california
this week it became the first state to
record more than three
million cases in los angeles the covet
situation is so bad officials say the
growing backlog of bodies awaiting
cremation
has become a public health threat the
air quality regulator in california has
temporarily lifted limits on cremations
so that more can take place to deal with
the backlog
canada is nowhere near that situation
though public health officials here warn
we're still at a dangerous point
and vaccine rollout delays are not
helping the government now says canada
will not receive any
pfizer biontech vaccines next week
because of production issues in europe
michael couture reports on how the
provinces are dealing with the delays
canada was informed of the decision
tuesday morning and it came
with even more bad news there will be
considerable impact across
all provinces asymmetric across the
board
the overall impact over the next month
is
in the range of 50 decrease of expected
allocations
the delays are being blamed on pfizer
needing to shut down production
temporarily
so it can expand it significantly
frontline doctors
understand the delay but it means
there's no let up
inside the icu having to uh see our
covert patients go through what they do
you know having to put on our ppe and
you see
often our nurses and respiratory
therapists in a room for
12 hours exhausted sweating and and just
you know having to to really go the
extra mile
now the delivery delays aren't happening
everywhere and not to the same extent
there are reports other countries in
europe have been using political
pressure to secure supplies of the
vaccine what are you doing if anything
to try and put pressure on these
companies to actually respect the
contracts we've signed
and we continue to work every day
reaching out to the top levels of
vaccine companies
including myself being involved to
ensure
that we are getting the doses we need
prime minister trudeau is trying to
reassure canadians deliveries will ramp
back up
and pfizer will hit its target of 4
million doses by the end of march but
ontario premier doug ford
is prodding the prime minister to do
more if i was in his shoes i'm sure he
is doing it but i'd be on that phone
call every single day i'd be up that
guy's yin yang
so far with a firecracker he wouldn't
know what hit him with from pfizer
canadian officials warn the road ahead
may not be as smooth as we want it to be
but they're confident everyone who wants
a vaccine
will be able to get one by the end of
september
donna all right mike locateur
in ottawa thanks well more regions in
new brunswick are moving into red zone
restrictions because covid case counts
keep rising
today that province reported 31 new
infections one of the biggest daily
jumps in new brunswick
and one more person has died as of
midnight tonight the moncton fredericton
and st
john regions will move to the red level
that means people must stick to their
household bubble
and gyms and salons must close the
premier is warning a full lockdown may
be needed
if cases keep rising there may soon be
some relief for people in manitoba
after more than two months of code red
restrictions the province
says the curve is now bending down and
it's considering loosening some rules
if the plan is approved as early as this
friday manitobans will be allowed to
invite two
additional people into their homes up to
five people will be able to gather
outdoors and retailers and hair salons
will be allowed to reopen
with precautions in place
we need to take this cautious approach
we know that
manitobans have always worked hard to
reduce the transmission of this virus
but we know that the more interactions
we have
we raise the the risks
the province says it will make a
decision on easing restrictions later
this week
dr russon warned there may be no changes
in the northern manitoba health region
which is more at risk of outbreaks
turmoil within the tories coming up how
the party is dealing with a
controversial mp
[Music]
prime minister justin trudeau says he
will continue to press the incoming
biden administration on the merits of
the keystone xl pipeline expansion
president-elect joe biden is poised to
make good on his promise to rescind the
permit for the project it's expected to
be among the first things he does
tomorrow today trudeau said he is making
sure canada's views are heard
over the past number of days and
continuing today we are
communicating our arguments in favor of
keystone xl
directly to the highest levels of this
administration
and we will continue to work closely
with them on this and
many other initiatives to protect jobs
and
and grow the economy in ways that also
fight climate change
biden campaigned on canceling the permit
for the 9 billion
pipeline project it's unlikely anything
can save it
now the federal conservative leader is
trying to send a strong message about
who is not welcome in the party
aaron o'toole has started the process to
remove mp derrick sloane from caucus
sloan has been connected to a string of
controversies and a recent donation from
a well-known white supremacist
seems to have been the last straw for
o'toole
with me is our ottawa bureau chief
mercedes stevenson mercedes
o'toole can't just kick sloane out i
understand what's the process that has
to unfold
you're right donna he doesn't have that
power as the leader of the conservative
party he has to have the majority of
mps in caucus vote for that and at 11
a.m
tomorrow morning in an emergency caucus
session that is exactly what
conservative mps are going to be voting
on
that's because the conservatives signed
on to something called the reform act
which handed the power to make decisions
about who should sit and caucus
to mps instead of the leader now that
said aaron o'toole has made his position
very clear
take a look at the statement that he put
out last night in which he said
racism is a disease of the soul
repugnant to our core values
it has no place in our country and it
has no place in the conservative party
of canada he is the one who has
initiated
the process to try to remove sloan and
he has said that he will not allow him
to run
in the next election now derek sloan is
defending
himself in all this he says he didn't
know it was a notorious white
nationalist and neo-nazi who donated to
his campaign
that he donated under a pseudonym and
online
that said donna a previous leadership
campaign by kelly leach caught
paul fromm trying to do the exact same
thing
in 2017 and today derek sloane came out
and accused paul fromm of being a member
of the conservative party
i can tell you we've just heard back
from the conservative party and they
confirm
that he did in fact hold a membership
listen to what they say
they say mr sloane's campaign derek
sloane's campaign
sold the membership to this individual
in may mr sloane's campaign accepted the
donation from this individual in august
we are revoking this membership we are
remitting the funds
we also sat down with derek sloan today
to ask him what he had to say for
himself
and here is what he told us i condemn
racist groups like this is not something
i'm a part of
or in any way associate with i'm not
trying to cause undue
uh issues for people but right now uh
the knives are pointed at me and i'm
gonna i'm gonna defend myself
so sloane vowing to defend himself as he
goes forward we'll see if he survives
the vote tomorrow donna i'm hearing from
conservative sources that that
is unlikely mercedes o'toola has often
supported derek sloane in the past why
is he doing this now
well donna conservative sources say that
this is really about
cumulative actions it's not so much
about the donation which his campaign
says they missed
it's about a whole accumulation of
behavior and derek sloan essentially
becoming a political liability to the
party
initially they thought they needed him
because of the social conservative base
he represented
but he's just had so many controversies
everything from the petition he brought
forward
which questioned whether the vaccines
for covid19 were human experimentation
to comments about gender identity and
beyond
they just can't afford to take the risk
of keeping him on board
okay mercedes stevenson in ottawa thanks
accused sex offender peter nygard is
back in court for a bail hearing nygaard
appeared via video link in a winnipeg
courtroom today
federal lawyers are questioning one of
his former executives who is offering
him a place to live if he's granted bail
nargaard was arrested in december under
the extradition act he faces nine counts
in the u.s
including sex trafficking and
racketeering nygaard's lawyer
argues keeping him in jail where there
are covet 19 cases
could be a death sentence for the 79
year old
ahead an expensive painting is
discovered stolen after
it was found
this highway north of tokyo became a
deadly scene after a blizzard triggered
a massive pileup
one person was killed at least 17 others
injured about 140 vehicles were involved
it stretched over one kilometer
crews worked for eight hours to free
those trapped and clear the wreckage
bad winter weather has been hitting
japan for weeks and more heavy snow is
forecast to fall
overnight workers trapped in a chinese
gold mine for nearly 10 days have
received more medical
and food supplies today the miners are
now able to communicate with their
rescue workers through a telephone line
today they asked for porridge and
pickles to be sent down
22 miners were trapped more than 600
meters underground
after an explosion damaged the access
shaft on january 10th
at least 12 of them are known to still
be alive they say they're suffering from
toxic
fumes and rising water levels though
wider rescue shafts
are now being drilled police in italy
have recovered a stolen 500 year old
copy of a leonardo da vinci painting
that was hidden
inside an apartment in naples and nobody
realized it was missing
until it was found the 16th century copy
thought to be painted by one of
davinci's students
is normally kept inside this church the
room where the painting was
on display had been closed for three
months due to covet 19.
there were no signs of a break-in it's
still unknown when the work of art was
taken or how
the painting was found in a bedroom
cupboard and a 36 year old man has been
arrested
next reflections on turning the page on
trump and the challenges
ahead
a presidential inauguration is usually a
centerpiece of american democracy
showcasing the peaceful transfer of
power this transition though has not
been peaceful
president trump's years of rhetoric and
lies plus covet covid19
have stirred up turmoil and apprehension
for many americans tomorrow
can't come soon enough here's eric
sorenson
i know you like me and this room is a
love fest at times
the presidency of donald trump seemed
endless it's now down to hours
day 1460 of the trump administration the
transfer of power from donald trump
taking place in
unprecedented conditions what should
have been a tranquil transition to a new
president
before a day of pomp and optimism for
the future has left many americans
shell-shocked looking now simply for
relief
an escape we have been literally under
duress
in this dire situation of the trump
you know spectacle because we are really
trying to
sigh and get over the trauma that we've
experienced
a tumultuous four years crowned by a
shocking scheme
not to transfer power peacefully this
was a fraudulent
election the chilling thought for many
was how close
donald trump came to winning re-election
in the end his management of the
covet-19 pandemic
exposed a president who appeared
concerned almost solely for his personal
interests
somebody that leaves a legacy of
corruption somebody that was impeached
twice
somebody that incited an insurrection
and somebody that utterly failed on
the biggest crisis that he had to see
over on his watch which was the
coronavirus pandemic
atop a pandemic and a fractured economy
there's a political chasm in america
that joe biden must try to bridge
america's endured much
and we will endure here and we will
prevail again
the challenge president-elect biden has
on his plate
are as difficult a set of challenges of
any president in modern history a man
clearly not in the prime of life but
right for the moment
he has a huge amount of experience he
has
a kind of calmness about him that i
think
is very appealing to people joe biden
will try to fix america at home
and repair its standing in the world i
hope that folks
in canada and around the world
give give america a chance under joe
biden the country's political wounds are
as raw as they've ever been on the eve
of a presidential inauguration
the healing under a new president will
take time
eric sorenson global news
and that is global national for this
tuesday i'm donna friesen
we leave you with more from the ceremony
tonight at the lincoln memorial
reflecting pool in washington d.c
it goes like this the fourth the fifth
the minor fall and the major lift
the baffled king composing
president-elect joe biden paid tribute
to the more than 400 000 americans who
have died of covid 19.
tomorrow he will be sworn in as the 46th
president of the united states
thanks for watching i'll see you
tomorrow for our live coverage of the
inauguration
for now take care of yourselves bye-bye